madame la ministre je veux aujourd'hui
vous parler de cararen elle n'a que 8
ans et se bat courageusement contre une
leucémie aigu chaque jour de vie en plus
est une victoire pour elle ces dernières
semaines la vie fragile de la petite
Caren a failli basculer en Guyane les
plaquette nécessair pour stabiliser son
état de santé manquait cruellement il
faut dire que la Guyane est actuellement
confronté à une forte épidémie de dingue
qui vient complexifier une gestion du
stock de plaquettes déjà sensible
faut-il rappeler que la collecte de sang
est suspendue en Guyane depuis près de
20 ans à la suite de l'extension de la
maladie de Chagas depuis 2005 donc le
sang transfusé au guyanais provient
essentiellement des Antilles ou de la
France hexagonale cette organisation
pose madame la ministre plusieurs
problèmes de santé publique il y a
d'abord la question évidente de la
disponibilité des stocks d'une part la
Guadeloupe n'est pas autosuffisante en
matière de produits sanguins Labil et
d'autre part la France hexagonale et les
Antilles se trouvent respectivement à 8
et 3h de vol et à 3h de vol aussi nous
ne pouvons taire la question des
phénotypes rares du fait de notre
diversité la Guyane dispose de groupes
sanguins rare l'utilisation de sang
n'appartenant pas à ces groupes
multiplie les risques d'incompatibilité
et de réaction transfusionnell il y a 2
ans j'avais interpellé le gouvernement
sur cette même question on m'avait
opposé rapport de santé publique France
ce rapport ne ferme pas la porte à une
reprise de la collecte du sang en Guyane
il dit tout au plus qu'il y aura des
contraintes nous savons qu'à l'arrêt de
la collecte de sang les actifs de l'fs
de Guyane ont été transférés en
Guadeloupe j'insiste là-dessus les
Guyanais on ont assez d'être les
sacrifiés combien de carenes faudra-t-il
madame la ministre avant que la France
envisage sérieusement de reprendre la
collecte de sang en Guyane vous pouvez à
présent autoriser au moins le
prélèvement de plaquettes qui bénéficie
d'un traitement rendant inactif les
virus ce sera un premier pas en
attendant que la recherche progresse
encore merci Madame la la sénatrice je
connais évidemment votre engagement pour
votre territoire territoire de la la
guyan vous le savez de manière
systématique quel que soit le le
territoire qui soit hexagonal ou
ultramarin ce sont systématiquement sur
des raisons épidémiologiques que des
collectes de sang peuvent être
interrompu il y a pas de discrimination
parce que ce serait tel ou tel
territoire ça peut être n'importe quel
territoire si jamais il y a un risque
tout simplement pour la santé publique
qu'ensuite les transfusions et bien se
fassent de manière défavorable en terme
de chance pour les patients et c'est la
raison pour laquelle en fait aujourd'hui
encore que soit pour la Guyenne ou pour
Mayotte ça n'est pas possible qu' est
ces collectes qui puissent être mis en
place je vais en reparler au sein du
gouvernement parce que j'entends bien
l'alerte que vous relancez sur le sujet
mais peut-être juste pour vous
réexpliquer ou redire pour tout le monde
est bien en tête pourquoi aujourd'hui ça
ça n'est pas possible d'abord parce que
en effet il y a eu un arrêté préfectoral
qui a mis en terme depuis 2005 c'est
vrai la collecte de sang en raison de la
présence de la maladie de Chagas qui
pose un véritable problème de santé
publique sur le continent sud-américain
et en Amérique latine puisque entre on
estime entre 15 et 20 millions de
personnes celles qui seraient infecté et
donc avec un risque très élevé de
transmission de de cette maladie donc
c'est vraiment la raison pour laquelle à
ce stade cette possibilité de don de
sang n'a pas pu être ouverte encore une
fois c'est uniquement sur des critères
de santé publique des critères
épidémiologiques mais comptez sur moi
pour remonter cette cette problématique
pour qu'on puisse vous apporter
éventuellement une notutre réponse ou
que d'autres études puissent être
réalisé puisque la la dernière date
d'août 2021 peut-être qu'une
réévaluation pourrait être lancée je
vous remercie